[Music]
for more than a century physicists have
tried to find a unified theory a single
mathematical framework capable of
describing all of nature's forces Albert
Einstein who unified space and time and
his special and general theories of
relativity pursued this goal for over 30
years
never succeeding today scientists are
continuing the quest seeking to combine
general relativity describing the
universe on large-scale stars and
galaxies with quantum mechanics
describing the universe on subatomic
scales each of these two theories works
amazingly well in its own domain but put
them together like in the dense center
of a black hole and the math falls apart
in the 1970s scientists came upon a
potential solution but from an
unexpected starting point studies of
nuclear processes in that era we were
trying to understand the strong nuclear
force it's just the force that holds the
nucleus of the atom together and that
was a complete mystery how to do it in
trying to solve that mystery physicists
were led to a promising equation that
seemed to describe vibrating strings
that would hold together atomic
constituents but within just a few years
a different theory proved to be the
right solution for understanding the
strong nuclear force and so strings no
longer seemed necessary almost all of
these several hundred people stopped
working on string theory at that time
and only a handful of diehards continued
to pursue them the few of us who
continued working on string theory felt
that the mathematics was so beautiful
and compelling that this theory had to
be good for something
much like Einstein who spent long
periods working on ideas outside the
mainstream Schwartz and his colleague
Joelle shirk continued to explore string
theory we realized what string theory
was good for and that was as a quantum
theory of gravity at that point I was
convinced that this is what I've been
working on to the rest of my career
Schwartz was proposing that string
theory which had failed as a theory of
the strong nuclear force was actually
the solution to one of the biggest
problems in all of physics uniting
gravity and quantum mechanics when
Schwartz excitedly announced this
prospect few people paid any attention
the field just wasn't ready so Schwartz
and a new convert Michael Greene spent
years developing the theory mostly on
their own then in 1984 they achieved a
breakthrough showing that the
mathematics of string theory deftly
avoided potentially lethal technical
issues and this time the community of
physicists heard them Princeton between
the University and the Institute for
Advanced Study you had almost half the
experts in the world who were working on
related topics and I am told that at
that point almost all of them dropped
what they were doing and became string
theorists as string theory rapidly
progressed there was a sense that
research was but a few years away from
uncovering the final and unified theory
of physics more than thirty years later
the goal of a fully unified and
thoroughly tested theory has yet to be
achieved but enthusiasm remains high
string theory has come closer than any
other attempt to go beyond known physics
and tackled the grand challenge of
unification but the question remains is
string theory an elegant mathematical
chimera for our string theorists rapidly
approaching the realization of
einstein's dream
[Music]